hi everyone I'm down like a bit the game
director of human reproduction and I'm
much none that assignment movie
productions today we are going to show
you our latest game the last tinker city
of colors it's a 3d action adventure set
in a very colorful place called tinker
world I'll give you a short introduction
to the game setting this story so the
game takes place in the city of colors a
very creative place where everybody used
to be an artist but at one point the
question arose which is the best color
in the world and people got so mental
about this that they even like stop
being creative and started to hate each
other so we players coral a young a job
boy from color town who brought the city
into extreme danger to a chain of
unfortunate events and now you have to
face them to do so you have to bring
back the people together and show them
whole stupid a dispute is so let's jump
right into
alright so here we are at the foot of
the great wingman and our goal for the
run will need to climb up there we are
accompanied by the green spirit that's
this little guy and he's the embodiment
of green color and all emotions tied to
it and right now he's afraid of
everything he didn't used to be like
that but right now he is and we have to
cure him by doing something really
thrilling and adventurous we can't go
through here the bleakness box our path
it's this white stuff that drains out
all the color and we will have to find a
different way around so yeah we just
called our friend tap and he kind of
shows us the way he's a nice friend that
always there for us so there is some
platform we have to do as you can see
it's like very food and accessible
because it's like one automatic jump
system where you hold on one button and
yeah he does jump before you he's not
the kind of guy like he knows how to
jump so you don't have to do the pics
perfect jumping you now enter the
cupboards and again writing kagura's is
not not so much about challenge this
challenging for sure that most of you
won't get through here on the very first
try but what we really want our game
play is to make traversal as fun as
possible you you just want to rush
through here and taking a leg like the
feeling of speed the food colors just
enjoy the game we have great fans of
games like banjo kazooie and jack and
dexter and justice is this happy
colorful feel of that and we put in
mechanics life needs to sort of update
these four for the modern
so now it just made it over the cholera
it's a little dial up again the green
square chin that's why guys are you sure
about what you gonna do like look at
this is just insane I can't climb up
there so please please don't do that
yeah we gonna do it so let's see how
we're gonna do this so it's six look
down right there so they're those
octopuses you see and they move like a a
pattern and you have to figure out the
pattern and if you don't you just want
to yeah following the water die but you
just respawn you just lost like one
health club so it's not too bad just try
it again now yeah yeah this time would
be much better and if you would die
completely there are checkpoints
throughout the novices it's not very
punishing so there's a combat segment
upcoming and then again color is very
very well accessible very small on
snappy but the special thing about our
permit is that we use color to invoke
emotions in Iranian so right now we use
cream to make them afraid and just
chased him off into the water and
quickly disposed of them that way you
will get three colors throughout the
game and each will do something
different to your enemies and just just
adds a whole new layer and the cool
thing is the Slayer also applies to the
puzzles look look at this guy is like a
bomb guy he's just like a kind of RAD
and he's angry and he's exploding he's a
bomb so rather startling motion hangar
Angelique's that's pretty simple so with
a local thing it would be like picking
up with green no address run off and be
like a min through that tunnel system so
we pick him off up there because you can
climb so yeah let's blow up in the war
yeah it's like this and now it's going
to be very cool because now there's some
combat and it can also use them in
combat nah we'd like pick him up and
having like
to the enemies and like just see how
cool that is a picture subscribe Miss
Mary food yeah this whole mission I'm
sorry yeah okay so need to calm that
down and what must not the only mushroom
creature you'll encounter there's also
this sky let's change it up this guy we
called bigs and totally different 4z
totally different character and totally
different reactions to our colors so if
we paint him green like cling to his
back and now we can steam around because
just he just runs away terrified we can
run through like tickles like these webs
so right now we are like half way up to
the entrance of the windmill and there's
this insanely fast spinning gear
blocking apart again we will have a big
helpers playlist we have this [ __ ]
here and this is having that to activate
it so we just place them on there we
make breakfast gets angry and stomps and
activates this year's far as and these
are rather simple puzzles we industry we
want you to get an overview for what is
possible with beaks and Bombur and all
the emotions you can make you can make
it my hair than half there are more
complex scenarios in the later game but
you didn't want to spoil them for you so
yeah through the tunnel you go and let's
go further up so against a little
platform here some nice poles more jump
run tricks let's see what there ah ok
the bats again so let's get big change
bomb where again yeah but just lean on
him and stuff over there were some
enemies so yeah yeah you see that that's
Rico we just run over the enemy so base
is a big help like I on you will like a
tough enemies but then you can like
still fight them so it's always good
they're pigs with you you just took like
helps you throughout the game so now
we're inside it's a screen spirit stone
again to protest against the whole plan
as you can see he still is not too
thrilled about the thought of climbing
there even though he can't I which just
shows how seemingly freitas of
everything but you want to tell us go
okay so that looks like these will pop
up throughout the game at a freaking
pace we didn't want to interrupt the
flow of gameplay too heavy we just like
inside with the snippets of story here
and there and so let me can develop a
nice rhythm like that characters like
green spirit them off them throughout
the game each has its own unique set of
problems you will have to solve like the
main theme of the game is that through
your actions you inspire them and dusty
them whatever emotionally complicated
thing they have so as you can see like
this part of the levels like very highly
focusing the platforming but like it's a
client if you have weakness kind of
protect us so it's not putting me onto
us and make that one more tense music
gets more intense if you listen
so let's see where we have to go yeah
that's weird part being and yet apt
where do you have to go okay we have to
go over there but as you can see there's
no way yet there so we have to figure
out this puzzle like how to turn the pie
so but yes that was that was pretty much
a platform level but they wouldn't like
very different ones
small combos or other ones that are like
totally crazy we have like a music caper
everything's like music themed and stuff
like this so we try to have like very
diverse yeah and maybe maybe you noticed
but like this giant gears and everything
but in no world is made of paper mache
and the glistening of cardboard some
connectors and it's we're really
satisfied with how this idea of a world
that is just tinker together came to
life and we can look really amazing so
let's see there's another convo what's
up there yeah Wow look at this this is
an awesome you oh like even the Queen
spirit is like cool what's that it's
amazing so you know guess what we want
him to guess that this is a cool
adventure so yeah you can see like some
important the links that you have been
before stuff so have a nice little view
of the world yeah and Suu you probably
notice the father we go up the my
excited beans becomes when there's we
reach the top he won't be a friend at
all anymore mean we want the story not
to be just some throwaway story forget
typhoon is after we wanted to have a
little more substance to be enjoyable by
everyone
so again we made it over Iran segment
and yeah latest following us please get
more intense and more intense yeah but I
can tell her like we're pretty close to
the top of the word milk this is just a
few more jumps we have to do it's tricky
here but we do find out thank yep
describe another row Jordan you here
again the tower which is one of the most
important but links in the world but I
will spoil of that yes figure that out
yourself so yeah well look at this so
and I think almost to the top and you
can see here the prosperity is going to
cure sort of adjustments go higher and
higher and I should high-five the son
who in turn them doesn't look too too
thrilled about the dangerous Amy we we
do here is just like more things come
down don't hurt yourself but yeah so
unfortunately this is the end of the
demo we're not gonna spoil you how to
bubble were actually but I really will
be enjoyed with you saw on the preview
the last take a city of colors will be
out pretty soon on Steam and you can
actually three on it right now
ah
you